[Music]
from the studio who wishes the 2010s
could last forever if only to keep their
Chinese theme park going rides and
attractions are obviously all based on
the Lion's gate films the gods of Egypt
roller coaster is one of the first
purpose-built roller coasters Comes A
desperate attempt to remind audiences
about The Hunger Games with an actress
equally desate to remind audiences that
she sings nothing you can take from me
the hunger Gates
World SC The Hunger Game I've fo the The
Hunger Games ballad we met up at
midnight The Hunger Games Ballad of song
Words The Hunger Games ballot of song
wordss and snakes we get it you can sing
this isn't a musical I wrote this song
about a boy back in 12 and I hope he
hears it wait is it a musical did I miss
something here how about a song
huh strap in for the confusing pointless
unnecessary prequel you never asked for
you know one time during the War I ate a
whole jar of paste about how corana snow
Grew From a failed fascist driven by
money you still want that plinth prize
don't you to a successful fascist driven
by a girl he fumbled as a teen you saved
me watch him drip with contempt for
everyone he meets and work through more
daddy issues than a brazer sound guy
with a busted mic you're General cr's
Snow's boy I know you want to be like
your father you'll end up dead in the
trees like your father you want to
protect people Mr
snow to govern them like your father I
think you look just like your father
your
father my best friend it's sto call in
it from me but whatever girls are roote
for anyone who looks like a young Donald
southernland a pouty blonde kid with a
shirt allergy have you seen tigis my
father's dress shirt Ah that's Dumber I
mean better that's
better now that rage Bay Channels have
squeezed all the juice from Brie Larson
and Ember herd it's Rachel Ziggler's
turn to pay their rent she's playing the
titular song bird Lucy gray UD done fell
off the turnup truck somewhere down Texa
laaya way you think I can't hear your
stomach growling just bigs when Lucy
gets picked in the pan MBA draft she'll
have to win the games by chilling in
various rooms doing
nothing then attack any unguarded
microphone within range and finally pull
off a high-stake seduction of her Mentor
snow is this real of course it's not
real clients and managers are natural
enemies remember the art of The Snow
Job witness the 10th annual Hunger Games
American America's second most boring
sport behind only baseball I'll freeze
the feed for an hour I estimate that's
all we have until the people notice it's
the government's live teen death battle
that for some reason is plagued by
symbolic acts of
defiance a profoundly dumb idea that
seems like it was a drunken joke because
it was I only Dred them up as an
assignment a joke I was drunk but years
before the games were Peak TV that all
of pan dream together they were a flop
where you slowly watch a grade schooler
die of
tuberculosis wo now it's up to snow to
Goose ratings with fun new twists like
don't keep the competitors in a
disgusting Zoo feed them some food maybe
and let fans in their favorite players
treats via drone as soon as they work
out the full self-driving
mode
even in the future nothing
works but Coro isn't the only anus in
this film meet the other characters like
sanus the neolution who wants to make
things better by having the same
conversation 10 different times the
tributes are human beings it's not your
fault to I know I'm so blameless I'm
choking on it maybe I become a medic
make a real difference out here just be
careful what were you thinking back
there she didn't do anything Coro you
trying to help these people don't you
think they need help whatever it is
you're doing you need to stop it I
couldn't make a difference if you want
to make real change you need to stay
alive how can I make any change from out
there now kiss Dr volumnia G bringing
some welcome diversity and
representation to the annual child
murder bowl a rainbow of Destruction
will engulf our Arena Peter Dinklage in
his favorite kind of role a brilliant
but World weary political adviser whose
regret over his misspend Youth and poor
choices have left him a bitter cynical
drunk also he knows things never been
done before lucky flickerman because all
dystopias are cursed with their own
unique James Cordon plus there's
returning favorites like tigis who by
panm standards is woke don't discount
her just because she's District Coro and
purely by coincidence broke vaa is
probably hiding in a log somewhere if
you pause at the right time cadiss
returns as we some people call it swamp
potato but I think catniss has a much
nicer ring don't you and who could
forget clemencia Dev coat Festus Creed L
Estrada Vickers Felix Raven Mayfair lip
Coral Spruce mizen Treach ma Ivory
Barbur have you tried this lamb it's
scandalous okay what is this Pokémon why
are there so many of you now get back in
the book
nerds so get ready for a swooning ya
Romance about inequality maybe we should
be viewing those tributes as human
beings full of the R-rated Carnage a
PG-13 movie loves to
[Applause]
imply while constantly reminding you
that violence is bad and you are a bad
person for wanting to see it the
monsters all of you they already made
four of these and now you're watching
the prequel what is wrong with you now
run along to the other Lion's gate theme
park in Dubai you sick little monkey get
fully immersed in the land of The Hunger
Games with the panm aerial
tour starring beards are op hey Lucy I'm
snow the G of this woman I killed a guy
with a trident cardly Rock Bottom
schwarzman out Hunter
flatterer Hugh Janis Huffington's post
and a traitorous kear player this is
just like what happened with Fleetwood
Mac The Hunger Games even Hitler had a
girlfriend let's rap kids I know kissing
and fighting is what's hit these days
but you know what isn't cool rabies did
you know that rabies makes you scared of
water rabies it makes you afraid of
water it doesn't but someday it could if
you've been bitten by a robot bat on a
box car train get checked
today saying please when you say please
say is pleasing to
say hi Jake you're a good
boy say my comment even though there is
no thought in it nor gives any value to
the
audience